primera aparición pública de Donald
Trump desde su imputación el viernes el
expresidente y precandidato a las
presidenciales de 2024 estuvo en el
estado de Georgia en una convención de
su partido donde movilizó a los
republicanos para obtener la nominación
Trump acusa a la justicia de intentar
apartarlo del poder con acusaciones
injustas
la ridícula infundada acusación contra
mí por parte del departamento de
injusticia de la Administración biden
pasará la historia como uno de los más
horribles abusos de poder en la historia
de nuestro país
está intentando encarcelar a su
principal oponente político el viernes
la justicia Federal reveló los 37 cargos
de acusación contra Trump que incluyen
retención ilegal de documentos
clasificados y obstrucción a la justicia
la fiscalía alega que el expresidente
guardó miles de documentos algunos ellos
altamente confidenciales cuando se fue
de la Casa Blanca en 2021 unos de estos
documentos incluirían información sobre
el programa nuclear de Estados Unidos
mientras Donald Trump niega las
acusaciones que calificó de broma la
fiscalía insistió sobre la gravedad de
los supuestos delitos a pesar de ser el
primer ex presidente de Estados Unidos
en ser imputado por cargos federales
Donald Trump sigue siendo el favorito
para las primarias republicanas de 2024
en las cuales se nominará el candidato
del partido para las presidenciales que
se enfrentará previsiblemente